This vertical distance is about forty five and eight tenths of a centimeter.
Nice problem solving if you got this correct.
We'll find this vertical leg by using
the Pythagorean theorem.
We know the horizontal distance are one leg
of the triangle is twenty units.
And we know the length of a string is fifty units.
Now our units are centimeters
but I'm just leaving it out as we work
through the problem.
We want to make sure we add that back in
when we get to our answer.
So twenty squared equals four hundred
and fifty squared equals two thousand five hundred.
Then we'll subtract four hundred from both sides of our equation
to get b squared equals two thousand one hundred.
We'll take the square root of both sides of the equation
indicating plus or minus.
But we'll only use the positive root
in the sense that we have a distance.
In this case b is about forty five and eighty two hundredths
Round it to the nearest tenth
we'll have forty five and eight tenths.
We've been working in centimeters
so we'll report this answer in centimeters.